[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un geste banal il ya
75 ans quand on découvre les effets du
micro ondes
on ouvre la porte à une petite
révolution dans les cuisines une
invention qu'on doit en partie au hasard
l'histoire commence quelques années plus
tôt
[Musique]
1939 à 1945
le monde est en guerre l'aviation fait
des ravages
pour limiter les dégâts on multiplie les
recherches sur le radar
l'invention clé ce sera ceux ci le
magnétron c'est un appareil qui génère
des ondes une fréquence bien précise des
micro-ondes le magnétron permet de
construire des radars plus petit et plus
puissant l'armée en installe dans les
avions et les camions et les navires
usines de raytheon aux états unis
produit des milliers de manier trop par
jour
avec la fin de la guerre l'entreprise a
besoin de nouveaux débouchés
c'est ici qu'intervient le hasard
la légende veut qu à l'automne 1945
l'ingénieur preuve si spencer s'approche
d'un magnétron avec dans sa poche une
friandise qui se met à fondre
[Musique]
il dépose immédiatement un brevet il
continue d'expérimenter avec des oeufs
et surtout des graines maïs le
fonctionnement d'un magnétron est assez
complexe
un courant électrique arrache des
électrons à la tige au centre et les
attire vers le pourtour de cuivre les
deux et main située au bout font tourner
les électrons en spirale ce mouvement
créé dans les cavités une différence de
charge électrique qui s'inverse
continuellement et à la bonne fréquence
ont créé des ondes pièces spécifiques
des micro ondes
ces ondes sont de la même nature que la
lumière dans le spectre
elles sont situées entre les ondes radio
et l'infrarouge et la lumière visible
loin donc des rayons x et gamma qui
peuvent être dangereux pour la santé
ces ondes rebondissent sur les parois de
métal dufour leur cible c'est avant tout
l'eau des aliments dans la molécule
d'eau h2o
il ya une petite différence de charge
électrique entre les deux pôles du
micro-ondes force les molécules d'eau à
se réorienter constamment
c'est ce frottement de molécules qui
crée la chaleur
[Musique]
en 1946 rione dévoile son premier modèle
le ridant reich un os qui rappelle ses
origines militaires il fait presque deux
mètres de haut et pèse 350 kg et souvent
l'équivalent de dizaines de milliers de
dollars d'aujourd'hui
ce sera un échec commercial dans les
années soixante du japon développe les
premiers modèles compacts
au départ les clients se méfie hésite
mais peu à peu le micro-ondes va
conquérir presque toutes les cuisines en
occident même s'il n'a pas détrôné le
four traditionnel il crée son lot de
nouvelles traditions
[Musique]